in season 7 episode 3 searching prison
Silurian thing gives tina kiss of death
thinking she poisoned her a bit later in
same episode now Jamie gives Alina
poison leaves thinking he poisoned her
did they really die matter of fact were
they even poisoned No
[Music]
as you can already tell in today's video
I'm bringing the possible final twist of
the Game of Thrones at this point you'll
expect Cersei to die by the hand of fear
her brother Jaime or Daenerys Targaryen
and her dragons however in this video
I'm bringing no fear if my name is Sir
she will actually be betrayed and killed
by her most trusted people basically
Qyburn has this whole time been working
for various and a mountain will betray
certain Chi burns order and I'll put an
end to the math Queen as she's her own
worst enemy and that mountain will talk
again there's plenty of proof clothes
hints and even some filming leagues are
supporting this theory of mine so let's
just jump in it from the very beginning
since the very first episode Qyburn
appeared on show they're raising more
and more yet and explained and
unanswered questions for example why did
Qyburn even decide to save the mountains
life life of the same man that severely
injured him almost killed him
lucky as I'm sure most of us remember
for unknown reasons sky burn ended up
among the northern and Riverlands
prisoners at Harrenhal surely after Sir
Gregor could gain a ban of the castle on
his all captives put a sword
Qyburn however survives the injury at
his throat and awakens from the castle
is taken by the northern army after he
wakes indentifies himself to Robb Stark
while Tallis attends to his wound so
Khyber saving the mountains life go back
in the third season almost kill him is
strange to say least another strange
fact is Skyrim being able to use spy
capabilities of same little birds that
verse used in previous seasons in case
you're wondering how can I be so sure
that Piper's little birds are the ones
that used to work for various it was
confirmed in season 6 episode 3 I don't
think so you miss him he was nice he
called us as little birds gave us sweets
it's funny you should mention that
that's what I happen to find today now
remember if any of your friends like
sweets will need help they can always
come to me all I need in return similar
birds Devere son Tyrion's concern about
their loyalty replied with man can be
fickle but bird Silas just from this
conversation we can see the various
fully believes his little birds and
bears can be considered as everything
but a fool additionally versus known as
a man of knowledge and whispers as a man
that knows every step of every living
man in the Seven Kingdoms Varys fully
trusts someone that someone will not
betray him even if that would mean the
death for that someone in case the no
little bird sees versus found a group of
spies which he educates give sweets and
provides them with protection in return
for the information they bring him his
sophisticated intelligence network which
is one of the largest in the world and
spans both Westeros
and esos due to his vast web of
intelligence sources verse is known as
the spider this fact gives me even more
doubt about where it's not knowing about
a group of spies that supposedly
betrayed him all of this means that
Qyburn is most likely working for
bearson is waiting for the right time to
be traced Circe and orchestrated her
death as well known Qyburn sir she
became extremely close considering the
fact that sir situated people around her
specially the just right once that
paranoia and suspicious thoughts
Qyburn however gain sirs his full trust
bringing kill gain back to life after he
was severely wounded during his fight
against oberyn martell
after death Circe named Qyburn as master
whispers as a versus replacement on a
small Council the thing is that even if
Qyburn managed to brief you versus all
birds and even if those few spice agreed
to betray Varys there's simply no way
that first wouldn't find it out there is
no way that none of his little birds
wouldn't send whisper to him if joy if
cabin truly does work for various this
would also raise a few important
questions I'm sure you're wondering if
Qyburn a little birds are loyal to we're
sweaty little birds in phone Qyburn
about wildfire later informed sir she
about eight which led to annihilation of
the great Sept of Baelor along with all
sources enemies before I give you an
answer on that question let me just
highlight one fact that you all have to
know before we continue verse has been
loyal to House Targaryen all the time
Varys has been serving Danny's father as
well he was one of the small amount of
people who served Mad King even when it
was obvious that he was going to lose
the war he nurses final days having
arrived at King's Landing with an entire
Lannister army at his back were sworn
the king not to open the gates which
Harris refused because of a grand
maester pycelle who told Matt King what
he wanted to hear buy/sell told him that
timing can be trusted the timing came to
save the day this resulted with the Mad
King opening the city gates which
resulted with the city being sacked and
aris himself being stabbed in the back
by Jaime verse has been working on a
plan to bring to the nearest Inn House
Targaryen back the Iron Throne that has
been taken from them since the fall of
House Targaryen
here we come to our ends to run a
question which was if Qyburn and little
birds are loyal to very sweaty little
birds inform Qyburn about wildfire who
later informed Cersei an answer and that
question is actually very simple search
this plan to destroy the great Sept of
Baelor along with all important people
in it match perfectly with vs. plan
additionally I think we're sexually
ordered Qyburn and his Oliver's to find
out if the Wildfire actually is under
the great Sept of Baelor and eventually
is to inform Cersei about it immediately
Varys is quite a smart man he was
aware that if sir suppose to wipe out
most of the leadership with wildfire it
was a result with her losing all her
allies and it woulda made a nice
conquest far easier and in fact that is
exactly what happened
Qyburn informed sir she about wildfire
knowing into the result just the way
dead just as wheres expected sir she
wiped out all her enemies and Elias
which gave him an opportunity to make
new allies for Danny in this case with
Olenna Tyrell Jesse Stone the future
from me she killed my son
she killed my grandson she killed my
granddaughter survival is not what I'm
after now right I chose the wrong words
it is not survival I offered it is your
heart's desire and what is my heart's
desire vengeance justice
fire and blood by the sack verse with
Qyburn self managed to provide a new
ally for his queen and made the nurses
take over even easier also the fact that
Qyburn birth could gain back to life who
back in third season slit his throat and
almost kill him is something that I
cannot get over it would only make sense
if it's a part of a bigger plan of
vengeance it could be the Qyburn created
monster only to get even closer to
Cersei which would allow them when the
time comes to easily kill Cersei while
she thinks that he's her most trusted
protector as the mountain monster closes
that the only guard throughout the past
few seasons it's a to say he will
continue to be in the final season as
well
if Qyburn truly works for Varys then
some of the main characters might still
be alive in season seven episode 3
searching prison Silurian thing gives me
a kiss of death thinking she poisoned
her a bit later in same episode now
Jamie gives Elena poison leaves thinking
he poisoned her did they really die
matter of fact were they even poisoned
no Qyburn is the one providing the
supposed poison to Cersei in the cells
the suppose poisoned Jamie gives to Lena
is also most likely coming from Qyburn
since his ancestors maester was there
really a poison or was it yet another
master plan of the cunning Spider Riders
if Qyburn is working for various not
only what it proved once again how
brilliant versus mind really is but it
will arguably be the greatest waste in
the Game of Thrones show
Cersei will be betrayed and killed by
her most trusted advisor Qyburn and
protect her the mountain while salmon
characters would turn out to be alive
and well there are even some season 8
filming news that could be going favor
to this theory
Amador Del Rio Kastle in Cordoba Spain
will return in Game of Thrones Season 8
which means they will revisit the
Tyrells stronghold
well then ass Castle reappearing in
season 8 even though she's supposedly
dead isn't the strangest part however
though we will see the castle Game of
Thrones is not filming there again
multiple sources confirmed that the
production will use leftover footage
from the first Almodovar shoot in 2016
for season 7 this means that there will
not be any new filming at Amador Del Rio
but the production will use scenes they
filmed for season 7 could it be that the
sim we're going to see has something to
do with the Lana
perhaps you're watching Jaime Lannister
and armies marching back home while they
think they just poisoned her in
conclusion all those theories combined
with all the proofs hints and clues
would most certainly make the greatest
face in the game of Thrones show and it
also seems like something that a
showrunner should pull out to leave us
the touch of speechless in the season
finale does this mean that the popular
Jaime killing stirs the theory will not
come true no as a matter of fact I don't
expect I burn or very
or even any of the characters that
search they think she killed that could
be alive to put an end on sources rain
I still think Jamie's great as the it is
going to be killing Cersei to prevent
her from burning down the entire capital
Jaime Lannister someone forgot to write
down all your great deeds best of time
is that for a four-year-old night with
one hand however even the two Hanna
Jamie will have trouble passing by the
mountain to come closer see but
considering that Jaime has been brave
and fearless his entire life no matter
that he lost his saying he will try to
kill both the mountain and Cersei of
course the Jaime most likely wouldn't be
able to pass by Sir Gregor Clegane he
probably wouldn't stand a chance against
the mountain who's near death only made
him stronger in this very moment I
expect the final twist to happen the
mountain on Kai burns order instead of
killing Jaime and defending Cersei will
actually help Jaime kill the Queen's
Guard and put an end to Cersei a wooden
learned that Qyburn has this whole time
been working for various well some
characters that Cersei thinks she killed
with poison that Qyburn provided would
actually turn out to be alive and well
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace